Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten.
Google schmeißt im Mai Apps aus dem Play Store, die heimlich Telefongespräche aufnehmen.
Beide sind unerwarteter Erfolg jetzt.
Logbuch-Netzpolitik Nummer 428 vom 25. April 222 und ich glaube wir haben uns ein bisschen Zeit gelassen oder seit der letzten Sendung. Ähm.
Oder wenig gehabt.
Will ich gehabt, äh was anderes zu tun gehabt. Manchmal muss man aber bestimmte Sachen auch einfach mal nachdenken.
Kopfnüsse sind so. Also im Mai schmeißt Google dann die Apps raus, die heimlich Telefongespräche abhören.
Ja das ist ja so ein altes Thema, das die Leute sich von ihrem Handy belauscht fühlen und ähm.
Ne? Ich habe über etwas nur da und da gesprochen, dann habe ich nachher Werbung dafür bekommen. Ich halte das nach wie vor eher im Bereich der Legenden, dass das tatsächlich auf diesem,
Niveau, was die Menschen da befürchten, tatsächlich groß großflächig stattfindet, aber es gibt Apps, die sich die Schnittstelle zu Barrierefreiheit zu Nutze machen und damit tatsächlich,
eben auf Gesprächsaufzeichnungen zugreifen.
Und das hatte Google quasi in seinen Appstore Richtlinien nicht nicht wirklich verboten und jetzt kündigen sie das eben an, dass sie so etwas nicht mehr,
zulassen werden, dann wird quasi der der Zugriff, der nicht zu barrierefreiheitszwecken stattfindet, ähm Verboten,
äh das dann eben auch äh ja so umgesetzt gegenüber Apps, die sie
aktuell im Play Store drin haben. Schon natürlich 'ne sehr unterhaltsame Sache, also das ist überhaupt 'ne zum Aufzeichnen der Gespräche und dass sie das Apps die auch noch nutzen und die dann Jahre später,
20, 22 einfällt.
Na ja, manchmal, ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie die ABIs so sind, aber du hast ja oft dieses Problem, dass in dem Moment, wo du in irgendeiner Form Unterstützung für Eingabe, Ausgabe, Systeme,
Möchtest für Blinde für sonst wie eingeschränkte.
Das ist dann viel zu breit ist, ne.
Ja und dass du dann auch so spezifischen Zugriff brauchst so. Ne, andere Tastatur, dann hast du eine Tastatur,
Plug-in und so weiter. So darf das dann sich mit dem Internet verbinden. So äh vielleicht erstmal nicht und äh wer darf das überhaupt installieren? Und wie wird das geprüft und so weiter? Das das ist äh
auch so betriebssystemspezifisch schon ein kniffliges Problem und äh sicherlich auch etwas, wo man nicht von vornherein immer alles richtig macht. So und dann muss man halt mal.
Solche Meldungen ermöglichen, damit wir da einen Witz drüber machen können. Ich finde das eigentlich auch ganz gut.
Aber der der äh die Meldung ist natürlich äh schon geil, wenn die wie heimliche Aufzeichnungen von Telefongesprächen. Google ändert am 11. Mai die Regeln, das ist eine spannende sehr unterhaltsame Meldung.
Google hätte Ihnen ja den HTTP-Status 428 schicken können,
Äh das ist nämlich ähm der schöne Status Pre-Condition Required. Ja, also da ist dann schon nochmal ja könnt ihr machen, aber dann müsst ihr bestimmte Bedingungen dann doch noch mal äh erfüllen,
Ja und sowas sowas kann man damit äh machen, um das gleich auch mal abgeworfen zu haben.
Wunderbar. Okay.
Schon mal Bescheid wissen so, ne.
Ja, nur dass du's schon mal weiß.
Ja genau, das ist nämlich das ist nämlich der kleine Bruder von 4hundertzwölf, den hatten wir schon mal so, wenn das halt nicht passt, dann dann ist das halt gefailt, so. Aber hier wird gesagt, es war auf jeden Fall.
Noch nicht mal angegeben, ja. Wir brauchen's überhaupt erstmal. Dann also dann wir du gibst erstmal eine vier achtundzwanzig und deine vier zwölf. Und dann guckste erstmal weiter.
Oder in die Röhre.
Die Arbeitsserver kannst du ja komplett in nächste Request kommt bestimmt.
Gut,
Dann wollen wir doch mal hier einsteigen in die tolle Sendung. Feedback haben wir wieder ganz viel äh bekommen. Ach Leute, das ist immer ich meine, man kriegt immer das so mit, wenn wir so reinrauschen, dann,
man sich das so äh manchmal ein bisschen aufmerksamer, manchmal weniger aufmerksamer durch und dann so wenn die Sendung dann irgendwann näher rauscht, dann blättert man nochmal durch den ganzen Wald, ist immer komplett erschlagen, so oh.
Siebzig Kommentare. Total super. Wir haben ein paar rausgesucht.
Und ähm vor allem habt ihr euch ähm erstmal wieder ein bisschen äh erregt über unsere Feststellung, dass ja die Corona-Warn-App jetzt so ein bisschen end of live ist.
Weiß jetzt nicht mehr so ganz genau, wie wir das jetzt gesagt haben, aber.
Es war primär. Ich habe gesagt ähm.
Bei so hoher Inzidenz äh schlägt dieses Konzept der,
Warnungen viel. Ja, weil sie oder meine meine Äußerung war, weil weil sie quasi,
zu häufig passiert und dann eben auch ohne Konsequenz ist und ich habe gesagt, dass eigentlich dieses Warnsystem und das eben Methoden sind für Niedriginzidenzzeiten
um Niedriginzidenz halten zu können. Das ist offensichtlich nicht mehr das erklärte Ziel.
Aus unterschiedlichen Gründen, auch weil wir jetzt es mit einer Virusvariante zu tun haben, die nicht mehr,
Gefahr birgt das Gesundheitssystem zu überlasten, so zumindest das, was einem,
In breiten Nachrichten erzählt wird, wenn man dann anschaut, wie Leute auf den.
Stationen das sehen, haben die damit unter auch andere Ansichten, ja weil die glaube ich auch einen anderen ähm,
Einen anderen Schwellwert haben für wir sind überlastet verständlicherweise, weil sie die Arbeit machen müssen.
Aber du hast ja bestimmt einen Kommentar dazu rausgesucht.
Habe ich ähm vielleicht noch mal dazu, also ich glaube, das hatten wir auch schon gesagt, ne? Also es ist äh,
die die Voraussetzungen sind jetzt andere und viele der eigentlichen Bedrohungen sind weg und diese Warmfunktion, ich meine da steckt ja auch im Namen,
Warn-App, so diese die er dafür da war rechtzeitig Bescheid zu sagen, damit man selber Drittinfektionen quasi einschränken kann. Ist natürlich jetzt auch mit dieser super.
Kurz, ich glaube das war jetzt ein bisschen kompliziert formuliert. Also wenn du die Warnung bekommst bist du ja wahrscheinlich schon positiv oder eben nicht,
kannst dann eben früh gewarnt sagen, ich schränke jetzt meine Kontakte ein oder nehme nicht an der Hochzeit teil, um dort nicht jemanden anzustecken oder ich lasse mich jetzt testen oder so was, ne? Das ist,
das ist ja das, wofür die App da ist und was was du meinst, dass nur so so sehr knapp gesagt.
Genau und dazu muss ja dieser ganze Warn-Turnaround mit Testen und Rückmeldungen und Auslieferungen und
Kenntnis nehmen, auch entsprechend schnell laufen und das war ja dann zu einem Zeitpunkt, als die Pandemie losging und dieser Zeitraum so im Bereich von vier, 5 Tagen war
durchaus noch ein realistisches Ziel und wird halt jetzt in zunehmenden Maße unrealistischer, wo wir's eben mit so einem äh so einer Inkubationszeit von zwei
bis 3 Tagen zu tun haben
Heißt nicht, dass es nicht auch noch irgendwie helfen kann. Zweite Perspektive war natürlich definitiv die Situation in Großstädten und ist natürlich klar
wenn du irgendwie unterwegs bist, dann dann hast du einfach so viel Kontakte und da wir uns einfach nicht mehr in dem selben Maße einschränken müssen und uns auch nicht mehr tun. Äh es ist,
mehr oder weniger zwangsläufig, dass dann in solchen Situationen,
mit so einem Lebensstil das Ding halt nur noch rot ist. Aber es gibt auch andere Perspektiven. Eine will ich vielleicht kurz rausgreifen, von Henning erschreibt
Eine Ergänzung äh zu eurer Lebensrealität der dauerroten CBA, dies mag für euch und andere gelten doch so viele Kontakte, die so viele Kontakte haben, dass diese Normalzustand ist.
Als jemand, der aus gesundheitlichen Gründen im privaten Umfeld jegliche Coronainfektion ungeachtet der Varianten vermeiden will, wahrscheinlich vermeiden muss und bisher auch vermieden hat,
ergänzen. Es gibt neben dieser Lebensrealität auch die Pandemie Realität von Menschen, die weiterhin so eingeschränkt leben, dass sie noch nie eine rote App hatten.
Ich persönlich habe die CWA je nach Zeitpunkt auf bis zu drei Mobilgeräten dabei und von denen war bisher nur eine App zu einem Zeitpunkt mal rot,
Da war ich mit idealem Eigenschutz,
einige Stunden am Berliner Hauptbahnhof in der Geflüchtetenhilfe aktiv, ansonsten dauert grüne Apps hier, weil ich aus Gründen weiterhin alle irgendwie vermeidbaren Kontakte vermeide.
Viele Schattenfamilien ist die Pandemie halt überhaupt nicht vorbei und für sie sind Dauergrüne Apps normal, auch wenn die CWA Farbe vielleicht nicht mehr beim Contact-Racing hilft,
vielleicht doch zur Messung, in welchem pandemischen Paralleluniversum Mensch lebt, umso wichtiger aber für Schattenfamilien,
Podcast produziert damit wenigstens diese Normalität aufrecht erhalten bleibt und okay ne andere.
Hat er auf jeden Fall einen Punkt. Allerdings und das ist ähm,
vielleicht auch mal etwas, wo man dann in Zukunft im Design dieses Warnsystems, wenn wir es denn noch mal brauchen sollten auch sich darüber Gedanken machen müsste, wie man sowas machen kann. Ich fand das ja immer schon,
Schade, dass es nicht so eine wirkliche, also man hat halt so diese Warnung, ja, aber was in diesem ganzen System halt so nicht drin ist, ist so ein so ein so eine automatisierte äh visualisierung des Gesamtbedrohungspotentials.
In meinem Umfeld, ne. Und das ist glaube ich das, wofür die App jetzt auf jeden Fall auch noch taucht. Meine, das war ja auch am Anfang so, da war sie immer grün, grün, grün und man dachte sich, wozu brauche ich denn das? Kaum hatten wir dann einmal so richtig fette Welle.
So, dann ging das halt auf einmal los und dann haben wir halt gemerkt, so, oh, das funktioniert ja sogar. Insofern war das ja auch ganz gut. Okay, das dazu.
Ja, ich frage mich auch manchmal, das ist aber äh wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Nie gekommen, äh wäre aber sinnvoll gewesen so eine die Warnung.
Also die überhaupt die wahren Geschwindigkeit zu erhöhen, dass man zum Beispiel bei einem positiven Schnelltest eine gelbe Warnung aussendet, ja. Ich,
bisher von wenigen Fällen gehört, wo die Schnelltests falsch positiv waren, falsch-negativ hasse,
Es gibt auch Fälle mit falsch-positiv. Im Schnelltest, ja, aber ähm.
Das das wären halt zum Beispiel Möglichkeiten gewesen, diese diese Meldegeschwindigkeiten zu erhöhen. Aber da wir in der letzten Sendung ja immer noch von der Hotline gesprochen haben, äh.
Ist er im Bereich der Automatisierung äh des gesamten Prozesses noch einiges zu verbessern.
Da ist noch nicht so viel passiert, ja und wird wahrscheinlich jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Glaube ich auch nicht, aber wer weiß wofür das noch mal gut sein kann. Das war jetzt sicherlich eine eine sinnvolle äh Erfahrung.
Dazu, wir haben ja oder wir haben ja auch gesagt, okay, das Konzept wird jetzt langsam von einer anderen Realität überholt oder eingeholt. Wenn man auch nicht gesagt,
man diese App jetzt deinstallieren soll. Wir haben gesagt die Luca-Apps soll man deinstallieren. Äh da kommen wir auch nachher nochmal zu. Insofern, wir benutzen die ja auch beide.
Immer noch, ja. Na klar.
Selbstverständlich, ähm weil sie nicht weh tut und äh gleichzeitig aber muss kann ich eben sagen, ich kann in.
Meiner Lebensrealität und da hat ja genau der Henning das den den wichtigen das wichtige Gegengewicht gebildet. Habe ich gesagt, ich in meiner Lebensrealität sind rote Warnungen jetzt nicht mehr.
Ähm in Handlung umsetzbar.
Während ich jetzt auch nicht den Eindruck habe, dass ich jetzt Unmengen an Kontakten habe, aber ich bewege mich eben durch diese Stadt und äh trotzdem ist das natürlich in einer, wenn du nicht an diesem Punkt bist,
Und wenn viele von euch das nicht sind, würde ich natürlich weiterhin entsprechend äh auf rote Warnungen reagieren, klar.
Insofern danke Henning für den Hinweis. Und viele andere, die ähnliche Kommentare hinterlassen haben.
Waren auch einige mehr.
Ähnliche Reaktionen auch zu unseren Kommentaren rund um Laptops, äh Lehrer, Schulen, Digitalisierung,
Das ist auch glaube ich so ein Thema, da kann man's auch irgendwie keinem recht machen. Also damit meine ich jetzt nicht euch Zuhörende, sondern halt irgendwie,
Generell glaube ich, kann man kann man's da nicht allen recht machen. Auf jeden Fall gab's sehr unterschiedliche
Einschätzung in den Kommentaren so rund um diese Dauerstreitfrage klappt denn nun die Digitalisierung im Unterricht oder nicht? Da gibt's positive Beispiele, gibt's negative Beispiele.
Ähm unter anderem wurde dann aber im Rahmen von Beschaffungsmaßnahmen Angst vor dem,
Apple Ökosystem geäußert, wo ich mich da wo ich mir dachte, so wie Apple Ökosystem, wo wird denn in Deutschland irgendwie Apple äh eingesetzt.
Weil das war ja immer schon so ein ewiges Universum, was da äh eigentlich stattgefunden hat.
Na ja, auf meinen angemeldeten Zweifel, dass man doch mit äh Sicherheit nicht zu Apple greifen würde, kam dann die Einschätzung von Felix und da lese ich mal vor.
Michels glauben, dass in Niedersachsen, also es ging in dem Fall um Niedersachsen, äh Apple gewählt wird, weil es in Niedersachsen schon sehr viele Schulen gibt, an denen die Eltern iPads über das Unternehmen Gesellschaft für digitale Bildung, für ihre Kinder samt Versicherung leasen.
In Niedersachsen die Medienpädagogische Beratung des niedersächsischen Landesinstituts für schulische Qualitätsentwicklung sehr auf iPads zugeschnitten. Das gibt unglaublich viele Angebote zu iPads und die regionalen Medienzentren legen Schulen auch direkt nahe iPads
einzuführen. Außerdem rollt die Landeshauptstadt Hannover gerade auch ein massives iPad-Programm aus und in dem Zuge werden in den Schulen gleich die PC-Räume abgeschafft,
deren Weiterfinanzierung steht in Frage. Informatik-Kolleginnen und Kollegen sind dort natürlich schwer verzweifelt, aus Admensicht, weiß ich aber auch,
wie gut sich iPads über ein MDM verwalten lassen.
Wobei die Vice Management ist das, ne. Ich kenne keine andere Lösung, wo man tausende Geräte so einfach verwalten.
So die Gründe, warum ich denke, dass die Wahl auf iPads fallen wird. Mein Punkt ist aber eigentlich der, dass iPads ohne sinnvolles pädagogisches Konzept ziemlich sinnlos sind. Außerdem wird soviel Bild verbrannt, was dann weg ist.
In Personal investieren damit jede Schule dann ein Admin bekommt um sich um die Schul-IT zu kümmern,
würde man nachhaltig Kompetenz aufbauen. Außerdem wäre das Geld auch besser in mehr Lehrerstellen investiert um die Unterrichtsversorgung zu verbessern,
Was mich auch umtreibt, ist der ökologische Fußabdruck dieser Idee. Alle drei Jahre bei allen Schülerinnen und Schülerinnen in Niedersachsen alle Tablets zu tauschen. Wir haben teilweise Linux, Business, Notebooks, die über zehn Jahre alt sind, aber dennoch einwandfrei und schnell funktionieren.
Ja da kann ich äh zuständig da ganz kurz einhaken darf, weil ähm.
Also hier sieht man wieder, okay, jetzt haben sie digitalen Unterricht. Wenn du jetzt sagst, okay, was ist.
Das perfekte Schulbuch für eine Schülerin heute, dann bist du natürlich bei so einer Tabletform.
Ja, weil du sagen kannst, okay, guck mal, wir können du kannst auf dem Ding dein Schulbuch digital lesen. Wir können potenziell, was weiß ich, irgendwelche Hausaufgaben äh
am iPad regeln, ne, das ist natürlich schon eine es ist ein leichtes Gerät.
Insofern für eine Digitalisierung des Unterrichts kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass da viele zu der Überzeugung geraten, dass das
iPad ein sinnvolles Gerät ist für die Schülerinnen und Schüler. Gleichzeitig sagt betone ich ja auch immer.
Das ähm ich irgendwie wahrscheinlich zu mit zu der letzten Generation gehöre oder zu der Generation gehöre, die einen Computer noch.
Von da ist ein Gerät mit Tastatur ohne Internet.
Zu. Da ist ein Gerät ohne Tastatur in meiner Tasche und hat immer Internet, so
bekommen habe und überhaupt noch gelernt habe, was ein Computer ist und mir graust es eigentlich und der vor, wenn Kinder, die jetzt oder vor, inzwischen kann man auch sagen, eigentlich
vor zehn Jahren oder sowas oder 15 Jahren geboren wurden deren erster Kontakt mit Computern war eben.
Ein leuchtendes Brett und dass dieses iPad eben sehr wenig eigene.
Informatiker oder Informatische ähm.
Kreationsmöglichkeiten bietet. Geht ja allein damit los, wenn du ein iPad hast, kannst du nicht damit ein iPad programmieren. Du kannst mit einem iPad äh du kannst ein iPad nur mit einem Computer programmieren und das heißt, die so das Wissen über wie,
funktioniert diese digitale Welt, um das zugänglich zu machen.
Darin auch kreatives Potential zu entfalten. Dafür brauchst du halt einen Computer und das ist, glaube ich, auch das, äh wo worauf hier Felix,
hinaus will, ne.
Ja, also mehrere Sachen. Also erstmal es ist halt einfach.
So, was er auch sagt, so iPads lassen sich einfach gut administrieren. Das irgendwie eine total solide Plattform, die existiert jetzt irgendwie schon seit zehn Jahren. Das funktioniert gut so und die Geräte sind in dem Sinne auch noch nicht mal teuer, wenn da halt jetzt wirklich so mit diesen,
Basismodellen einsteigst und das ist natürlich ein ganz wichtiges Ding. Was du sagst ist natürlich interessant und ich glaube das ist auch so ein bisschen so eine Perspektive,
die so aus unserer Computer-Bubble heraus immer kam, weil wir halt gesagt haben, oh wenn man mit Computern arbeitet, dann müssen ja auch Computer selbst,
interessant sein. Man lernt ja dann Computer,
Ich glaube, darum geht's hier gar nicht so sehr. Hier geht's um die Digitalisierung, hier geht's darum, die den Unterricht zu flexibilisieren und nicht um die Geräte als solche. Ja?
Kann da noch mit dazukommen, aber wenn ich irgendwie meine Schulbücher über Physik und Biologie darauf habe und da irgendwelche interaktiven Dinger habe und jederzeit Lehrfilme abspielen kann
et cetera. Äh ich meine, Fahrschule mache ich irgendwie auch im Webbrowser. Das funktioniert auch besser als mir irgendwie durch irgendwelche Bücher äh äh durchzublättern.
Vollkommen normal heutzutage und Ähnliches, was halt gut damit gemacht werden kann. Das soll doch bitte, bitte, bitte
dann auch gut damit gemacht werden. Und wenn's iPads sind, gut, weil,
Ökosystem, ich glaube diese Vorstellung davon, dass wenn man jetzt irgendwie ein paar Jahre lang irgendwie ein iPad als als quasi als universelles Schulbuch benutzt,
dass man dann irgendwie nur noch nach Apple schreit, das ist auch ein Glaube, von dem ich nicht denke, dass dass,
der stimmt so. Also das äh da haben wir wirklich andere Sorgen und das sieht man ja auch und die Einschätzung hier vom Kommentar war ja auch so dieses wir brauchen halt trotzdem erstmal Personal,
Weil es oft auch einfach die Lehrer sind und das hatten wir ja letztes Mal auch angesprochen, die einfach gar nicht die Zeit haben, die dafür gar nicht bezahlt werden, gar nicht ausgebildet werden, dann auch äh da in ein System zu,
einzusteigen und so ihre Lehre zu machen und sich gleich von allem zu verabschieden, was sie äh bisher gemacht haben. Das ist wahrscheinlich einfach ein langwidriger Prozess, weil bei uns der Druck einfach nie hoch war,
Corona hat da jetzt so ein bisschen was verbessert, aber na ja. Ich habe noch einen zweiten Kommentar, den will ich noch hinterherwerfen, dann können wir das Thema auch abschließen. Äh Thomas schreibt.
Denke, dass schulische Digitalisierung ein ähnlicher ClusterFuck ist, wie es Lillet damals zum Bildesministerium erzählt hat,
auf der RC 3 Einsatz in meine Präsentation eingebaut, den ich vorher zu den Corona Apps gehört hatte,
Digitalisierung muss man von vornherein denken, doch niemand im Schulsystem kann das. Die Verantwortlichen sind entweder Lehrkräfte oder Juristinnen, die Lehrkräfte unten sind überlastet.
Von Regelungen bedroht, die Kommunen versuchen das so preiswert wie möglich über die Bühne zu bringen, allein der Prozess um die Kohle vom Digitalpakt zu bekommen,
ist absurdes Theater aber nicht sinnführend,
Dazu kommen dann noch digital Evangelistinnen unter den Lehrkräften und Didaktikerinnen, die alle das gelobte Land sehen, aber nie konkret werden.
Mit Fortbildungen zugeschissen, die nix tun als dich zu erklären, wie du die Dinge, die du vorher mit einer Tafel gemacht hast, jetzt mit einer App machst
Die zentralen Fragen wie wie machen wir Medienbildung, was ist überhaupt digitale Schulung, was bedeutet sie für den Alltag von allen Beteiligten, welche Ziele haben wir gesellschaftlich, wenn wir von einem digitalisierten Schulwessen sprechen, wird alles aus meiner Sicht überhaupt nicht diskutiert,
Da wird überall furchtbar gewurschtelt, weil die Forderung im Raum steht es zu machen,
Das war's dann auch. Schule und Bildung müsste mit allen Stakeholdern von vornherein digital neu gedacht werden, aber das funktioniert natürlich nicht, weil die Jugend, die Minderheit in diesem Land ist und so und so nur begrenzt, bekannt ist,
dass es jenseits von Grundschule und Gymnasium äh noch etwas existiert. Ich habe mich jetzt viel zu lange damit beschäftigt, dass es mich noch überrascht,
Link noch auf diesen Talk. Ähm ja also da das ja auch in den Kommentaren auch noch mal an anderer Stelle angesprochen wurde, also.
Wir dissen jetzt hier auch irgendwie nicht die Lehrer. Äh ich sehe das einfach. Ich ehrlich gesagt, ich diss da gar keinen. Weil ich sehe halt einfach nur eine komplexe Gesamtkonstellation, wo es bisher noch niemanden gelungen ist,
Knoten zu lösen und der wird sich wahrscheinlich erst langsam freiruppeln, ähm weil einfach niemand mit einem passenden Schwert daneben steht.
Ähm irgendwie kulturell nicht so richtig auffette kriegen.
Ich habe jetzt mal meine Vermutung, welchen Vortrag Thomas meint in auch noch mit in die aufgenommen.
So dann hatten wir noch äh.
Dann gibt's ganz viel Brokkoli.
Rückenbehältung zu äh Brokkoli.
Doch auch mit Brokkoli machen.
Ja also ich sprach ja von Käsekuchen, von dem ich meine, dass da kein.
Brokkoli reinkommt, aber Andy,
Noch an. Ganz kurz zu den Themen Brokkoli und Kuchen, lieber Tim, das will man auch im Kuchen haben und auch mit Käse. Also lieber Tim, lieber Linus, packt das gehamsterte Mehl aus und probiert mal diese zwei Rezepte aus. Links sind anbei.
Das machen wir nicht hin. So geht das los. So geht das nämlich los. Das machen wir nicht.
Was? Wieso? Herzhafter Brokkoli Chicorée, Haselnussblätterteigkuchen? Gehe ich mit?
Am Ende investieren wir in Bitcoin.
Und Lachs, Brokkolikuchen.
Klingt super. Ich habe ja direkt gesagt, das ist für Gesamtbrokkoli.
Es ist halt einfach, man muss für Brokkoli einfach auch den richtigen Bereich finden. Da kann es dann auch irgendwie was bewirken, ja, aber Käsekuchen ist es nicht.
Also herzhafter Brokkoli Creme, Chicorée, Haselnussblätterteigkuchen und Lachsbrokkolikkuchen sind das Bitcoin des Brokkoli.
Ja
Okay.
Noch einen Kommentar hatten wir zu unserer kurzen Diskussion um äh Online-Wahlen. Da reagieren wir ja dann immer ähm ein bisschen gereizt, weil wir da so meinungsstark sind.
Gab dann noch einen längeren Kommentar von äh Kolja.
Der, ich greife es gleich mal vorweg äh in der Partei Volt äh engagiert ist, das ist diese,
europäische Partei.
Also von sowohl von den Themen als auch von ihrer Organisationsform, die es halt in allen EU-Staaten gibt oder zumindest in allen geben soll und in vielen gibt.
Er schreibt, ich freue mich sehr darüber, dass ihr Online-Wahlen thematisiert habt, da ich mich gerade im Rahmen meiner,
Arbeit, damit befasse ich. Folge eurer Argumentation hinsichtlich Parlamentswahlen, die Omnipräsenz der Kriterien in der Wahlcomputerentscheidung des Verfassungsgerichts.
Jedoch eine problematische und unvorhergesehene Konsequenz für unsere Demokratie an anderer Stelle. Sie hebelt in Parteien die Rechte einfacher Mitglieder aus, indem sie neben Delegiertensystemen keine anderen Parteitagsformen praktisch anwendbar macht.
Innenausschuss des Bundestages hat für die temporäre Einführung von Online-Parteitagen während Corona eben jenes Kriterium,
anstatt digital Übersatzungsänderungen und Wahlen abstimmen zu können, müssen diese in einem separaten Briefwahlgang bestätigt werden. Da Briefe teuer und einfache Parteimitglieder unzuverlässig sind,
sich selbst reformwillige Parteien für ein Delegiertensystem anstatt von Mitgliederparteitagen um die benötigen Quoren einzuhalten und damit handlungsfähig zu bleiben,
Es ist nämlich weder garantiert, dass eine Vorabstimmung auf dem Online-Parteitag das Briefwahlergebnis widerspiegelt,
Doch dass alle Mitglieder die Briefwahlunterlagen zurücksenden,
auslaufende coronaregeln sind ohnehin Präsenzparteitage notwendig, besonders verwirrend wird die Entscheidung des Innenausschusses,
Die Alternativen betrachtet bei Online-Parteitagen bestand die Wahl zwischen Briefwahl und Online-Wahl. Bei dem Urteil zur Wahlcomputern war die Alternative eine Urnenwahl. Die Briefwahl wird aufgrund der höheren Wahlbeteiligung akzeptiert,
obwohl die Wahlrechtsgrundsätze nicht eingehalten werden können. Das wäre also grundsätzlich auch für Onlinewahlen in Parteien möglich.
Die umstrittene Anwendung des Kriteriums auf das Parteienrecht bremst die Entwicklung neuer Beteiligungsformen praktisch aus. Überlegt euch mal, wie schön es wäre, wenn Parteimitglieder nicht nur online Anträge stellen, sondern mit ihrer eigenen Stimme Wahlprogramme und Satzungsänderungen
abstimmen könnten, wollt Deutschland hat während covid-Online-Parteitage durchgeführt, bei denen jedes Mitglied dieselbe Stimme durch ein Krypto thoken,
dem mal an hier ist jetzt nicht äh Krypto Geld gemeint, sondern er ist in Kryptographie. Äh durch einen Krypto token hatte. Das hat viele Menschen angezogen, die nebenher inhaltliche Parteipolitik machen wollen.
Die sich nicht auf die Wahl von Delegierten und Wahlkampfunterstützung beschränkt. Diesen Sommer
ist mit diesem demokratischen Traum Schluss und wir werden notgedrungen ein Delegiertensystem einführen. Die Alternative bestünde darin, wie die Piratenpartei mit dieser Parteitage in Präsenz zu veranstalten,
an denen nur ein besonders aktives Klientel teilnimmt,
Piraten gegen den Basisentscheid Online BEO oder die ständige Mitgliederversammlung als Parteitagsform sind zwar vielfältig drehen sich jedoch im Kern auch um die Auslegung der Kriterien,
im Parteienrecht. Okay, das war jetzt ein langer Kommentar, aber ich fand's mal wertvoll, dass äh hier wiederzugeben.
Ja, also ist natürlich ein Punkt, ne, muss man mal sagen. So
es ist natürlich klar, dass in einer idealen Welt, in einer idealen, digitalen Welt, so dieser direkte äh Zugriff auf äh eine Organisation oder eine Organisation auf seine Mitglieder,
Ihre Mitglieder wünschenswert wäre, wenn es gerade um so etwas geht wie Meinungsbildung. Und in gewisser Hinsicht kann man das ja machen, bloß,
an dem Punkt, wo man eben abstimmen möchte und sich wirklich ähm auf etwas einigen möchte, auf Basis von von Mehrheitsentscheidung.
Läuft man ja letzten Endes in dasselbe Problem und wahrscheinlich muss man ja auch mal abwägen, wie quasi das jeweilige Gefährdungspotential ist. Nichtsdestotrotz,
ist es natürlich so, überall da, wo dann Einflussnahme problematisch ist und da kam, glaube ich, die Piratenpartei auch ein Lied von singen.
Ähm wie viele Leute dann auf einmal angelaufen kamen, als das Projekt erstmal ein bisschen Erfolg hatte
die vielleicht gar nicht so wohl meine Intention hatten, um dann quasi das Projekt auch von von innen zu äh ja durch irgendwie libatäre äh Träume auf der einen Seite und irgendwie so latent äh,
problematische Leute, sage ich mal auf der anderen Seite, die man sich alle noch so reingeholt und reingerufen hat in diesem,
Rausch des Wachstums.
Ja, dann dann hatte man auf einmal so eine gesamt Gemengelage unter den Mitgliedern, mit denen man nicht mehr klar kam und dann war auch halt diese Auseinandersetzung auf diesen Parteitagen irgendwie keine Freude.
Diese ganzen Vor-Ort-Parteitage sind eben genau daran gestorben. So alle können halt mit mitmachen, aber eben nur, wenn man vor Ort ist und das bedeutete dann, dass immer so die.
Sag mal, ist etwas stramm so die größten Sesselpupser, äh die besten Chancen hatten irgendwie äh das Programm zu gestalten,
Leute, die vielleicht irgendwie Kinder und sonst irgendwie einen Job haben, eben nicht die Möglichkeit hatten, mal eben beliebiges Wochenende auf so einem Parteitag rumzugammeln.
Und klar, dann ist natürlich das Delegiertensystem bei uns so, dass äh etablierte Systeme und man trifft halt eine Vorauswahl für Leute, mit denen man in irgendeiner Form vertraut,
der Ansatz, den's damals bei den Piraten gab, also in irgendeiner Form mit so einem,
permanenten äh Parteitag online quasi so eine so eine fortwährende Meinungsbildung,
zu betreiben natürlich auch problematisch, weil du schnell wieder in diese Probleme reinläuft mit Komplexität des Systems, Vertrauen in das System et cetera, so gut es auch gebaut und gemeint gewesen sein mag,
dann auch nicht alle dazu durchringen das zu benutzen. Weiß nicht, hast du da irgendwie eine Meinung zu Linus?
Klingt für mich nach so einem Bereich, wo leider ideal und.
Realität so ein bisschen aneinander knallen weil.
Also wichtige Entscheidungen leben ja auch ein bisschen davon, dass man vielleicht den Kreis der entscheidenden,
festlegt und ich glaube eine Stärke solcher Delegiertensysteme ist, dass in der Regel wenigstens diese delegierte Person dann
im Namen derer abstimmt, die sie delegiert haben
und mit denen vielleicht auch eine Rücksprache hält und dafür oder sich zumindest darüber Gedanken macht, die richtige Stimme abzugeben.
Während wenn du jetzt sagst, okay wir machen alles offen, alles basisdemokratisch.
Äh das also man sieht ja, wohin das also man sieht, dass es in der Realität Parteien bisher noch nicht so hinbekommen haben.
Um das mal vorsichtig zu sagen, damit zu arbeiten, ne, dann entstehen dann kann auf einmal jede eine Abstimmung machen,
dann hast du potenziell die falsche Struktur in deinen Abstimmungen, in so der Gestalt, dass ich halt quasi,
Themenüberlappungen zwischen unterschiedlichen Abstimmungen gibt, dann ist immer nicht klar, wer sich gerade berufen fühlt oder dann hat mal jemand
den Überblick verloren, weist sich an welcher Abstimmung ich mich beteiligen soll. Dann hat die auf einmal stattgefunden, ohne dass ich es wusste. Da sind also so eine Reihe an.
Ja Komplikationen drin, die meine Eindruck nach noch nicht so sinnvoll gelöst wurden,
nicht, ob's da wie hießen die denn ein Liquid und oder Liquid Feedback oder was?
Genau, ja, das waren ja so die, also Liquid Deprogressiver, eher das Konzept.
Genau.
War das konkrete äh System ähm was letzten Endes so ein bisschen die Basis für so einen permanenten Parteitag ist, der so,
der einen Seite online ist, aber auf der anderen Seite auch noch einen Delegiertenmodell äh dahingehend enthielt, als dass man eben themenspezifisch seine Stimme auch,
solchen Delegierten ähm übergeben kann. Also ich kann entscheiden.
Was weiß ich hier, wenn's um Security geht, so dann soll mal der Linus das entscheiden, weil da habe ich eh keinen Plan von, aber ich vertraue dir, dass der dass der Linus das schon irgendwie macht.
Stimmt, das hatten die ja. Ja, ja, stimmt.
So, das war so die das Modell und ich fand das eigentlich auch immer ganz charmant, aber es ist natürlich trotzdem eben auch ein sehr technokratischer Ansatz, der dann äh,
erstmal die Leute wiederum begünstigt, die eben in solchen technokratischen Kontexten auch gut arbeiten können, was eben mitnichten für jeden
passt, ja, andere brauchen einfach so die offene Debatte und die Diskussion um den Punkt und bereiten sich lieber in Gesprächsrunden mit ähm einem eingeschränkten Team vor.
Das ist etwas, das muss ich erst noch mal evolutionär beweisen, dass das wirklich funktioniert und da muss ich halt auch sagen, so schön die Idee von Liquid Feedback ist, ich habe das jetzt nicht an vielen Stellen reduzieren sehen,
Nicht so, dass jetzt irgendwie andere Gruppen gesagt haben, oh wow, super, tolles Modell, ja? Ist zwar technisch sehr interessant und auch so,
mit dieser Nachvollziehbarkeit der
Beschlüsse und wieder abgestimmt wird und wie gerecht diese Abstimmungen sind, ne? Weil sie halt äh nach so einem äh elaborierten äh,
Verfahren äh arbeiten, Schulze-Methode et cetera, also wo soll sozusagen wird die Gewichtung der Stimmen gut ist und nicht nur so plumpe Mehrheiten und äh
eine Rolle spielen. Das war schon alles ganz gut, aber trotzdem zeigt sich eben, dass dass das noch nicht so unmittelbar an Menschen andockt.
Dass das eben ein System allein ein Computerprogramm allein
da nicht hilft. So und jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, okay gut, ne, wir wollen aber nur, dass die Leute von zu Hause wählen können, mehr wollen wir doch gar nicht, denn dann dann brauchen wir diese Delegierten nicht, dann können ja alle mitstimmen. Ja okay, gut, kann man machen, kann man kann man.
Mitexperimentieren. Habt ihr bei Volt ja offensichtlich jetzt auch getan, habe jetzt nicht viel rausgelesen, was diesen,
Traum, wie es hier formuliert war, untermauert mit Erfahrung. Wer nochmal interessant das zu äh hören, welche Erfahrungen das gegeben hat, aber ich denke da sind wir noch nicht. Nichtsdestotrotz in dem Moment, wo,
Volt ist jetzt irgendwie Regierungspartei, ja und es ist klar, dass jetzt eine ähm,
Parteientscheidung zu einem bestimmten Thema ähm durchaus Relevanz hat, gerade wenn das,
so ein Online-System und so ein so eine äh Massenbeteiligung dann auch hochgewichtet wird in der
Partei und dann irgendwie Koalitionsrelevanz hat et cetera dann werden natürlich auch die Kräfte stärker, die versuchen so etwas zu beeinflussen.
Und dann stellt sich irgendwann natürlich wieder die Security Frage. Ich will jetzt erst nicht auch damit alles komplett,
ich denke, dass wir ähm vielleicht experimentieren müssen mit Nuancen davon?
Es muss auf jeden Fall klar sein, dass wir irgendwie so diese unmittelbare Machtdelegation, also die Zuteilung von Ämtern ähm et cetera.
Freihalten müssen von solchen Betrugssystemen. Ich meine, wir haben früher immer viel darüber gewitzelt so, was äh die Russen vielleicht für einen Einfluss haben können mit ihrer ganzen
Expertise Systeme aufzumachen und es gab ja schon immer die Berichte auch mit den Waldcomputern in den USA
Mittlerweile wissen wir halt wie groß das Interesse ist äh,
Russland wird jetzt nicht nur über Russland ziehen, sondern generell natürlich gibt's auch andere äh Staaten und Gruppen, die gerne Einfluss nehmen wollen,
Wenn sie's denn können und in dem Moment, wo sie's können, machen sie's dann halt auch und das hat uns irgendwie,
Wahrscheinlich auch Trump eingebrockt, also jetzt nicht konkret online Wahl und auch nicht unbedingt die die äh Wahlcomputer, ne, aber die Beeinflussung über das Digitale und das geht,
dann eben auch bis dahin äh Brexit, nächste Beispiel und in Frankreich sind wir jetzt grad mal wieder von der Schippe gesprungen.
Soviel dazu.
Dann gibt's noch was Schönes. Eine schöne, ein schöner Kommentar von Julia.
Genau. Julia schreibt, hallo in die Runde. Ich gestehe nicht alle Kommentare geflissen, die ich gelesen zu haben, aber gerade beim äh Überlegen könnte ich eine kleine Erwähnung,
zum Aufmacher Major der allwissenden Müllhalde finden, deswegen möchte ich hier meinen heutigen Zufallsfund teilen.
Majory Vicky DE. Die Müllhalde von.
Heißt die doch, oder?
Oder hast du in Deutschland dann Majory?
Heißt.
Ehrlich gesagt gar nicht. Heißt die nur allwissende Müllhalde oder heißt sie Majurie, die ähm oder Marge Marge, Entschuldigung, jetzt war ich zu deutsch.
Zu deutsch. Ja? Also nochmal.
Ja, für den Briten bisschen zu deutsch.
Das ist eine rein pragmatische Entscheidung. Da wissen die Leute, wie's geschrieben ist, ja.
Et cetera wenn ich richtig Englisch reden würde, würde mich da wieder kein Mensch verstehen. Dann ist es auch alles nur so daher geredet. Also.
Ist die Wikipedia bei der abgelehnte ein schwarze Chance erhalten. Die heißt Margery.
Das erhellte mir den Start ins Wochenende sehr.
Mir auch, Julia. Ich glaube, ich wusste das auch schon mal, aber ich habe das verlegt. Aber das Margerit, das äh da wo die ganzen abgefragten Artikel äh hinkommen, die sonst ähm keine Chance haben.
Okay, dann haben wir in der letzten Sendung ja,
mal wieder über Heckbacks geredet, das ist die Hackpack Illusion, die ja Leute äh immer wieder umtreibt ähm.
Um es nochmal zusammenzufassen. Es ist nicht so, dass man spontan mal etwas hackt.
Geht nur sinnvoll, wenn man das äh langfristig quasi vorbereitet ähm oder sagen wir mal so, es wäre sehr die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist gering,
wenn man gerade angegriffen wird in sehr schneller Zeit eine,
durch Hacking dem ein Ende bereitet
Ja, das gibt es andere Methoden, wie man dem Angriff ein ein Ende bereitet, äh zurückhacken, spontan
ist äh die unwahrscheinliche, unwahrscheinlichste Variante davon, wenn es halt das auch so ähm selten.
Ja, funktioniert. So, jetzt gab es dazu ja eine klare Positionierung im Koalitionsvertrag.
Ähm und diese.
Diese Formulierung heißt sogenannte lehnen wir ab. Warum lehnt man die ab? Erstens weil es ähm.
Wenn man hacken möchte, braucht man dafür Schwachstellen. Das bedeutet also, vor allem, wenn man schnell und spontan hacken möchte, muss man Schwachstellen geheim halten. Das wiederum geht zu,
eigenen Lasten.
Weitere Argumente sind ja auch, dass insbesondere in so einer schnellen Situation man nicht unbedingt erkennt, wen wo kommt denn jetzt der Angriff her und wie
was der denn jetzt mal schnell weg, ja und deswegen ist in meinen Augen die einzig,
sinnvolle Konsequenz, wenn man sich jetzt offensiv beteiligen möchte, dass man das macht, was andere auch machen, langfristig vorher infiltrieren.
Und dann im Fall des Interesses einen Schaden beifügen. Das geht aber natürlich nur mit den Zielen, die man im Rahmen quasi eines,
gezielten Angriffs eines Cyber-Wars.
Vorher angreift, ja? Und du kannst jetzt nicht sagen, ah okay, äh der Russe hackt unsere kritischen Infrastrukturen.
Deswegen hätten wir jetzt mal präventiv den Russen, falls der irgendwas kaputt macht
ja? Die Situation ist ja eher, dass die Monate drin hängen, keiner etwas merkt und dann hast du den Schaden. Also diese ganze Diskussion leider wirklich völlig falsch aufgestellt von Leuten, die eben keine Ahnung haben, wie man hackt und wie nicht.
Leider das war ja schon in der letzten Sendung hatte die Bundesinnenministerin Nancy Feser die jetzt das befürwortet,
die FDP hat ja jetzt auf ihrem Parteitag auch drüber diskutiert und jetzt wurde der BSI-Präsident interviewt, dass es,
kein so gutes Zeichen und hm zwar beim Redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland. Jetzt müssen wir kurz auseinandernehmen, was er gesagt hat. Im Falle eines Falles geht es auch darum,
Datenströme zu unterbinden und den Zugriff der Angreifer zu beenden korrekt.
Es gibt bestimmte Formen von Gegenmaßnahmen, die dazu beitragen können, zum Beispiel die Abschaltung von Kontrollservern von Bordnetzen.
Richtig, also korrekt Situation ist folgende, sagen wir mal ein Unternehmen ist ähm.
Infiltriert worden, gehen wir mal davon aus, es geht jetzt nicht um
Heck, der unmittelbaren äh Schaden, unmittelbare Störung hervorruft, sondern zum Beispiel um Spionage, ja? Dann kannst du jetzt dieses eine Unternehmen relativ einfach verteidigen, indem du sagst, okay
diesen DNS-Server schalten wir platt ne oder diesen DNS-Eintrag überschreiben wir mit einem Think Hall oder diese IP-Routen wir nicht mehr ja und es wäre aber natürlich dann eine potenziell sinnvolle Maßnahme, dass
auch auf Deutschland ebene zu tun. Wir haben in der letzten Sendung auch darüber gesprochen.
Das Microsoft äh Think Holding ähm betrieben hat zur Beendigung von Bod Netzen. Übrigens.
Kannst du noch mal kurz sagen, was Thinkholling ist?
Ja ja, das ist äh hatten wir in der letzten Sendung schon mal erklärt, dass so den Traffic umleitest. Also du es gibt äh gibt irgendwie eine Domain,
die die Angreifer benutzen, um ihre IP zu finden
Das machen sie deshalb, weil sie davon ausgehen müssen, dass sie ihre IP regelmäßig ändern müssen, weil ihre Server vielleicht hochgenommen werden, aber solange sie die Domain kontrollieren, können sie ja immer woanders hinzeigen lassen.
Ja? Oder du hast zum Beispiel in deiner Schadsoftware drin, dass der eine Liste von Domains hat?
Wenn die erste, was weiß ich, gesperrt wurde, so nimmt er einfach die zweite. Ja, solche Dinge. Und ich habe in der letzten Sendung ja mich gewundert, weil in diesem Artikel, den ich gelesen hatte, nicht drin stand, wie Microsoft sich denn in dieser Domains.
Bemächtigt hat und äh tatsächlich war es so, dass sie das jetzt gerade wieder getan haben und zwar mit einem äh Botnet, das äh wie heißt es denn?
Setloader oder Seeloader, ja und da haben sie sechs 65 Domains in ihr Thinkholling-Programm aufgenommen.
Und das machen sie, dass dass sie die quasi beschlagnahmen lassen über einen Gerichtsbeschluss. Also die haben beim United States District Court for the Nerven District of Georgia ähm,
quasi per Gerichtsbeschluss diese Dinger äh diese diese Domains zugesprochen bekommen.
Und lassen die jetzt auf ihre auf ihren laufen. Und das Thinkhol ist dann in der Regel ein Server, der vielleicht, sage ich mal, noch die Zugriffe lockt, um dir nachher einen Überblick zu geben und zu sagen, pass mal auf, ich kriege hier.
200 Zugriffe am Tag, 5 davon,
aus dem Land, 15 aus dem anderen. Das sind die IP-Adressen. Kannst ja mal gucken, ob du mit denen irgendetwas anfangen willst oder auch du erkennst dann irgendwann, es werden weniger, ne, solche derartige Dinge. Also Think Holding ist das, was äh hier,
Arne Schönbomben benennt und das halte ich jetzt für also das Argument ist zu machen.
Aber auch überhaupt nichts mit Heckback zu tun, sondern mit einer äh ja sagen wir mit einem Eingriff in das DNS.
Um das Routen bösartiger äh Domains oder bekanntermaßen bösartiger verwendeter Domains,
zu verhindern und den Zugriff darauf, Routing hat ja jetzt gar nichts mit zu tun. Das Auflösen solcher Domains zu verhindern.
Ist eigentlich eine Verteidigungsmaßnahme.
Ja und hier eben könnte man also man könnte eben sagen, die die das wäre ja potenziell, etwas, was man auch auf einer äh Regierungsebene anbringen könnte.
Hm da sei kurz noch zu erwähnt, wir erinnern uns, dass wir mit äh Felix Reeder ja hier gesprochen hatten über die,
also diesen DNS-Anbieter, der unter anderem auch dir die Möglichkeit bietet oder der Best Afport betreibt Margaret Domains eben nicht aufzulösen.
Wurde dann Sony gesagt hat, ja gut, dann könnte er auch direkt mal die diese Piratenseiten nicht mehr auflösen. Das ist ja das Anhängige-Verfahren äh von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte,
also das fällt alles noch unter den Gegenmaßnahmen, wo ein das Argument zubringen ist.
Dass damit ähm Angriffe verhindert werden und potenziell wenig weiterer Schaden angerichtet wird, insbesondere weil du nur einen Prozess dafür brauchst oder eine rechtliche Grundlage.
Die natürlich ihre Lücken haben kann und ihre Probleme, aber du brauchst keine Schwachstellen. Ähm weiterhin sagt er aber dann,
tiefe Gegenmaßnahmen, also,
auch hilfreich sein, um zu verhindern, dass auf Servern gespeicherte, erbeuterte erbeutete Datensätze weiter abfließen.
Also Vorstellung hier ist, du hast ein Wort Netz, es fließen Daten ab, ja, du weißt, Leute sind gehackt, du hast jetzt eine Schadsoftware gefunden, die schickt ihre Daten an ein äh Command and Confort Server, jetzt sagst du alles klar, wir
lassen den jetzt mal sink holen, holen uns einen Gerichtsbeschluss vom Georgia oder was auch immer,
und leiten diese Dinger um, ja.
Mittels ne? Das glaube ich in.
Ja, genau, jetzt leitest du das irgendwie um. Ja und jetzt sagt er, jetzt sind aber die Daten da drauf aufm Server und die haben die Angreifer, die ja noch nicht abgezogen von dort. Die liegen da ja nur.
Ja ja.
Ne und jetzt müssen wir aktiv, jetzt machen wir.
Und nehme dir die Daten wieder weg, weil die ja keine Backups machen oder weil die die ja sicherlich nicht schon längst ausgewertet haben.
Ähm das müsste aber, sagt er dann auch, fein austariert und wohl überlegt sein. Viel Glück mal eben schnell einen Commander Control Server zu hacken und das fein auszutarieren und wohl überlegt zu machen. Ähm.
Ich erinnere mich also es gibt Fälle, muss man tatsächlich sagen, in denen so etwas äh funktioniert hat, ja? Und zwar tatsächlich auch ähm.
Durchaus einige, wo dann eben gelungen ist, die Server der Angreifer ähm zu übernehmen. Äh ich kenne auch persönlich von von einem Fall mit, wo dann tatsächlich
Der Server übernommen wurde, wo die ganzen Wenzeles drin standen. Ähm also auch das jetzt eine.
Option. Ähm allerdings natürlich keine, wo jetzt grade die Leute für argumentieren,
Worauf sie suchen, ja? Insofern ähm weiß ich nicht, ob das jetzt eine sinnvolle Wortmeldung war.
In einer solchen Debatte jetzt, ne, wo alle denken, der Russe schaltet uns den Strom ab aufgrund des äh des Kriegs, den Wladimir Putin gegen die Ukraine führt, dass dann das BSI,
einer so nicht informierten Debatte nun.
Ja, eine eine Nuance hinzufügt, die am Ende von allen nur gelesen wird, als der BSI-Präsident will den Hackpark. Ja und äh das ist äh denke ich. Also,
der wäre mir dann die potentielle Schadensminderung durch das Zugreifen auf potenziell schon gelöschte Daten,
potenziell bereits weiterkopierte Daten äh irgendwie nicht sinnvoll in Einklang damit zu bringen, dass man jetzt eine offen ähm.
Kapazität aufbaut und damit eben Schwachstellen potenziell zurückhält. Also es ist eine.
Ein schwieriger Bereich und ich hätte es in der letzten Sendung ja auch schon gesagt, in der Regel geht es bei diesen ganzen Heckback-Geschichten eben mehr darum, wie formulierst du das denn in ein Gesetz, dass es nur dann,
möglich ist und erlaubt ist und auch funktioniert und auch etwas bringt, wenn es sich wirklich um eine abwehrende, defensive Maßnahme handelt und nicht,
du eingesetzt hast, was dir mit seinen zu starken Einschränkungen.
Eigentlich gar nicht mehr ermöglicht irgendwelche Maßnahmen zu deinem Schutz zu ergreifen oder.
Dir so viel Freiraum gibt, dass du Maßnahmen zu deinem Schutz ergreifen kannst, aber nur indem du einfach die ganze Zeit den Feind selber heckst. Und das ist, denke ich, das, was hier,
dass das Problem ist ja und das kommt und sieht man auch hier dem in dieser Debatte.
Dass alle immer von Hack-Back reden, wären das nicht das ist, was jetzt, sage ich mal, Leute im Innenministerium und beim Militär sich gerne wünschen,
meine eindringliche Warnung ist ja, dass der Text, der da am Ende stehen wird, sofern so etwas beschlossen würde, wird irgendwie sein,
der und der darf Heckenpunkt.
Und dann wird als nächstes äh der Begriff Hackback aufgebohrt. Da finden sie dann irgendein neues äh fancy Wort, was wir brauchen.
Dann hast du innerhalb kürzester Zeit halt eine.
Offensiv Kapazitäten in der Bundesregierung, die dürfen hacken, wen sie wollen, ja? Also so läuft es ja auch mit Überwachungsmaßnahmen, so läuft es ja auch mit den hackigen Befugnissen, die sie jetzt schon haben,
Was also das Aufbringen von Staatstrojanern angeht, es wird ja so getan, als wäre das kein Hack,
das ist ja, das ist ja eine staatlich angeordnete Maßnahme, ja. Ich bitte dich,
Ne, also das ist äh ich denke, da das ist grade sehr tragisch, dass diese Diskussion in uninformiert geführt wird und während ähm.
Zumindest mal eine also eine halbwegs äh nicht ganz völlig unsinnige Wortäußerung inhaltlicher Weise hier stattgefunden hat ähm ist sie äh doch.
Eben das Öffnen einer Büchse der Pandora und das Spiel mit dem Feuer vor dem Hintergrund,
eine Regierung daraus macht und welche Debatte hier eigentlich gerade geführt wird. Noch dazu bei allem
bei aller Liebe, das sind halt wirklich enorm seltene Fälle, wo du ernsthaft sagst, jetzt hecke ich aber die Angreifer zurück
hast damit spontanen Erfolg und selbst wenn es dann jetzt so jetzt holst dir die Daten zurück überleg mal wie lange das dauert die zurückzukopieren,
Ja, also das ist alles ähm nicht wirklich. Das das deckt sich nicht mit der Hacking Realität, die da draußen stattfindet.
Ja, so läuft's.
Tja ähm dann haben wir den Digital Services Act. Da gab's jetzt Trilog. 16 Stunden Diskussionsmarathon.
Und damit scheint sich die Europäische Union jetzt über den Digital Services Act ähm.
Geeinigt zu haben, allerdings noch nicht in Schriftform. Das heißt, diese Dokumente, die kommen erst noch, was wir also jetzt kurz berichten, ist ein kurzer Überblick, über den das, worüber Sie sich wohl einig geworden sind.
Und wir werden dann, denke ich, im weiteren Verlauf nochmal den Patrick Breier in der Sendung haben. Am ehesten, wenn es jetzt auch an die Ausformulierung geht.
Ja, was also abgewehrt wurde, war, dass man bei äh Erwachsenenwebseiten hoch von hochladenden,
Telefonnummern sammelt, weil das kannst du dir auch vorstellen.
Das kommt jetzt nicht. Yay.
Das Lied, ne? Das liegt, da hätte ich mich so drauf gefreut.
Weißt du irgendwie so wenn dann irgendwann mal da so ein kleiner Hackback stattfindet und äh und du zu jedem Pornovideo irgendwie auch noch die hochladende Person dazu hast.
Das wäre äh wäre eigentlich ganz gut gewesen.
Genau und dann kannst du kannst du dir gleich zeigen lassen, was dein Nachbar so mochte, dann hast du's nicht so weit.
Also sehr geehrte sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen, meine Telefonnummer hat sich geändert. Aha. Warum denn.
Nee, das ist also ich meine, da muss man wirklich sagen, was für eine Schnapsidee. Ähm.
Löschpflichtenversuchmaschinen sind nicht mit aufgenommen worden. Ähm kein umfassendes Verbot personalisierter Werbung. Also die Idee war, tatsächlich zu sagen
personalisierte Werbung wird sowieso verboten. Wir legen den ganzen Sumpf trocken. Stattdessen sagen sie jetzt ja okay
nur bestimmte sensible Daten dürfen nicht mit in diese personalisierte Werbung mit einfließen.
Äh also was weiß ich, ne? Ähm,
politische Gesinnung oder ähnliches, weil die ja ohnehin nicht direkt erschlossen werden. Also das Problem bei der personalisierten Werbung ist ja, dass sie nicht mal unbedingt,
Daten erfasst, sondern.
Sie sich aus ihrer Masse an Daten erschließen kann und daran kannst du dir gar nicht mehr hindern, ja? Also äh weil sie dich eben über diese Webseiten tracken, weil sie deine das, was du dir anschaust loggen,
können Sie eben zumindest, sage ich mal, nicht unterscheiden, ob du eine spannende Recherche zu Nazi-Inhalten machst oder ob du ähm.
Eben einer Biss. Äh das ist also die Beschränkung äh eher nicht ausreichend. Kein Verbot von,
automatisierten Filtersystem, also wäre jetzt mal eine Möglichkeit gewesen zu sagen, hier automatisierte Filter, wo wir verbieten, da muss irgendwie eine,
informierte Entscheidungen stattfinden, auch nicht verboten wurden und eine klare Stärkung von Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung hat auch nicht stattgefunden.
Stattdessen gibt es einen stärker definierten Schutz vor ebenso personalisierter,
Überwachungswerbung bei Minderjährigen, also die genießen einen besseren Schutz vor
personalisierter Werbung als äh erwachsene Menschen. Einen besseren Schutz vor Produktfälschungen bei eBay und Amazon, ja, das ist äh die lassen einen damit eher alleine, weil sie sagen, wir sind ja hier nur die Handelsplattformen, das ist jetzt dein Problem, wenn,
da jetzt eine Produktfälschung erhalten hast, das heißt da werden sie mehr in ihre Verantwortung gezogen. Es soll Algorithmentransparenz kommen.
Aber da ist der da steht der Text noch nicht und da muss man dann eben schauen, wie das da je nachdem, wie das formuliert ist, dann natürlich auch eine sehr schöne Transparenzsimulation stattfinden kann. Ähm.
Was soll denn das heißen, Algorithmentransparenz?
Ja wenn da wenn du automatisierte Entscheidungsfindungen hast,
du deinen Besucherinnen und Besuchern irgend ein White Paper bereitstellst, in dem drinsteht, so ungefähr funktioniert das. Aber es ist, du hast natürlich total Recht, die meisten Sachen basieren eben heute.
Nicht mehr auf dem, was man Algorithmus nennt, sondern der Algorithmus ist,
eine massive Datensammlung mit Entscheidungsregeln,
sodass hier wahrscheinlich, wenn jemand sagt, so ungefähr machen wir das. Wir nehmen alle Daten und dann gucken wir. Ne, das ist ja der Algorithmus letztendlich. Wenn du hier so eine AI äh am Laufen hast, dass da also eher eine Transparenzsimulation stattfinden wird.
Dann sollen die Plattformen Risikoanalysen über ihre Auswirkungen auf die Gesellschaft,
anfertigen lassen, um ihren gesellschaftlichen ihr gesellschaftliches Schadenspotenzial halt auch klar selber
zu bekennen, erkennen. Ich denke, das ist hier so ein bisschen der Bezug auf Francis Horgan, die er auch sagt, so Leute, das wussten die bei Facebook auch, was wir jeden Tag in der Zeitung gelesen haben, dass die Kinder sich inzwischen
oder dass die Jugendlichen und und jungen Menschen inzwischen bei der äh bei der plastischen Chirurgie im Prinzip Instagramfilteranfragen und nix mehr essen,
So also das dazu sollen sie quasi verpflichtet werden hm es soll Daten Zugangsrechte,
von diesen Plattformen für Forschung und NGOs geben, damit eben auch besser extern erfasst und überwacht werden kann, was bei denen abläuft
Das könnte natürlich ein ein Highlight werden für mehr Rechenschaft, bin ich aber mal gespannt. Ich glaube, das wird einfach nur Streit geben und ähm.
Stelle ich mir schön vor, diese Risikoanalysen der Plattform so. Das ist ja so ein bisschen wie so auf Zigaretten dann so diese Aufdrucke. Doch sich bei Facebook ein und kriegst dann erstmal so eine.
Die sollen sich erst
selber damit, ich ich denke, es geht hier eher darum, dass die das nicht dass sie nicht behaupten können, sie wüssten's nicht, ne? Aber alles, alles, was ich gerade sage, ist noch nicht in finaler Schriftform, insofern muss man gucken, ob das ob das irgendwelcher Quatsch wird oder ähm ernst.
Ich meine so ein so ein großer, dicker, fetter Banner, der bei Facebook beim Login steht, mit Facebook gefährdet ihre mentale Gesundheit?
Viele sind hier hängen geblieben.
Das hat die Tabakindustrie aber auch über Jahrzehnte geschafft zu verhindern, ne? Also in in in einem Ausmaß, dass Menschen ähm.
In manchen Ländern mehr, in manchen Ländern weniger so. Ich meine, kannst du ja mal äh angucken, wie weit die Tabakindustrie Neuseeland gekommen ist.
Also.
Gibt's keine Tabakindust.
Nochmal, wir werden's sehen, ne? Ich denke nicht, dass das hier also hier steht nicht, du musst einen Warnhinweis aufbringen, sondern hier steht, du musst quasi deine eigenen Risiken erforschen, ja und die, ich denke, die Konsequenz daraus ist, ähm,
du wirst.
Du kannst dann nicht mehr sagen, dass dir das nicht klar war. Das war ja das das ist ja der der Gag bei Francis Horgan, dass sie im Prinzip, was sie gesagt hat, waren ja äh relativ also mit gesunden Menschenverstand relativ offensichtlich zugängliche,
Phänomene. Der entscheidende Punkt war, dass sie gesagt hat, die wissen das und die handeln trotz dieses Wissens nicht anders.
Ja und das denke ich wäre hier mit so einer Verpflichtung eben der die Reaktion darauf.
Bisschen bessere Nutzerinnenrechte bei der Inhaltmoderation, also große Plattformen müssen, wenn du jetzt einen Inhalt gelöscht kriegst oder geshadowband wird oder gesperrt wirst, müssen sie dich informieren und dir einen Beschwerdeweg anbieten.
Und bei falschen Sperrungen eben insbesondere auch, ja? Das heißt, wenn jetzt irgendwie sanktioniert wirst in so einem sozialen Netz, dann müssen die dir sagen, hier, das machen wir.
Und hier ist deine Möglichkeit, dich darüber zu beschweren. Das wird lustig und ähm dann sollen.
Dark Patterns für die Einwilligung verboten werden. Da bin ich aber mal gespannt, wie Sie das formulieren, ne? Ich meine, diese Dark Patterns für die Einwilligung, die hast du auf jeder Webseite, also äh um's nochmal kurz zu erklären, die,
wo du auf eine Webseite gehst und die ist einfach so gebaut, dass das, was du eigentlich möchtest.
So kompliziert ist und irgendwie leicht, grau in äh auf auf leicht der Grau, äh auf irgend so einen kleinen Einpixelgroßen Knopf steht, während ein riesender, großer, blinkender Knopf sagt, hier klicken,
mit dem du alle deine Rechte abgibst, ja? Das soll das wollen sie also verbieten, bin ich mal gespannt, wie.
Oder so Account anlegen äh mit einem Klick-Account löschen, ist so ein KafK S ist Kafka Skess Labyrinth von einem Millionen Menüs mit unterschiedlichen User-Interfaces, die dich permanent im Kreis schicken und am Ende gibst du einfach.
Genau.
Ne, das irgendwie einfach mit also die einfach wo einfach mit der Tradition gebrochen wird, dass der nächste Knopf, der dir angeboten ist, der ist der auch in deinem Sinne ist.
Ja? Äh oder zu deinem Schutz dient, hm was wir eben also wir kennen diese Cookie-Bänder. Mal gucken, die haben sie aber damals auch verkackt. Insofern mal schauen, wie sie jetzt das Verbot von Dark Patterns hinkriegen.
Der spannende Teil ist, der die Durchsetzung.
Dieses Digital Service ist Act. Soll bei einem Verbund der Kommission liegen.
Damit du nicht einen Race to the Bottom hast, wie du's im Datenschutz hast, wo ähm dass man ja das Irrland Promodem kennt, wo alle ihren juristischen Sitz in Ihr Land haben,
damit Sie bloß nicht in der Situation landen, dass Sie deutschen Datenschützer diskutieren müssen.
Das ist interessant, also mit Verbund meinst du jetzt äh irgend so eine Agentur, die dann quasi der Kommission angegliedert ist?
Ich denke, dass also die kommen dass die Kommission sich dann in ihr eigenes Gremium schafft und sagt, wir dieses Gremium setzt das jetzt durch,
und zwar einheitlich in der EU und nicht äh ne, nicht irgendwie irgendeiner geht hin und sagt, wir machen die Arbeit nicht und hat dann auf einmal plötzlich Facebook und sonst was in seinem Land äh mit einem Briefkasten vertreten.
Das ist ganz interessant. Lasst uns das Thema aber ähm mit Patrick äh nochmal besprechen. Sobald der Text steht.
Dann haben wir Neues,
Von Pegasus, also Citizen Lab hat wieder neue neue Forschungsergebnisse über Pegasus. Wenn man so einmal so ein.
So eine die ordentlichen Direktionsregeln hat und vielleicht.
Ne, den guten Kontakt zu den Leuten, dann kann man da offenbar sehr viel erkennen und die haben jetzt äh erstmal festgestellt, dass aus dem Büro des britischen Premiers Boris Johnson,
ähm offenbar 2020 und 2021 Hinweise auf eine Infektion mit Pegasus gefunden worden sein, also Ten Downing Street und außerdem beim ehemaligen Fored and Common worth Office.
Vielleicht noch mal kurz erwähnen, was Pegasus ist. Pegasus ist so das Spyware von NSO. Von dieser NSO-Group für Mobiltelefone.
Die ja, man sollte noch dazu sagen, dass es ein Staatstrojaner ist, ne, also kannst du nicht einfach so holen, sondern du musst schon eine Unrechtsstaat sein und Kunde des Unternehmens, NSO Group mit Sitz in Tel Aviv, glaube ich.
Außerdem haben sie ähm festgestellt, dass mindestens 65 Personen aus der autonomen Region Katalonien.
Also in Spanien Ziel von Pegasus waren,
Bei 51 Personen haben Sie ausreichende Hinweise auf eine Infektion gefunden, darunter auch Europaparlamentarierinnen super, wer hat denn wohl wer
könnte denn jetzt die autonome Region Katalonien irgendwie angreifen? Das würde mich jetzt, da frage ich mich natürlich, ob's vielleicht die Spanier waren?
Als sie dir haben Feinde, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Nicht verstehen, ne? Äh jeder katalonische Präsident seit 2010 wurde gehackt. Entweder während der ähm,
während sie im Amt waren, bevor sie gewählt wurden oder sogar nach ihrem Ruhestand, äh die äh mehrere officials, die also in dem in der katalonischen Regierung sind, wurden gehackt,
jedes katalanische Mitglied des Europäischen Parlaments, dass die äh Independenz, also die Unabhängigkeit Kataloniens, unterstützt hat. Außerdem ihre Mitarbeiter.
Geil, ne? Katalonische äh katalanische Mitglieder der Zivilgesellschaft inklusive Anwälte, die äh Katalanen repräsentiert haben.
Familie.
Familienmitglieder.
Ja, wunderbar. Außerdem haben sie sich jetzt nicht auf spanischen Grund beschränkt, sondern auch in Richtung der Schweiz gehackt. Also super, ne? Das ist eine echt eine Spitzen.
Schwitzen-Tool, ja. Ähm der Explode, der dafür genutzt wurde, ähm.
Wurde vermutlich in iOS 31zwei gefixt.
Und ähm aber sie erkennen halt jetzt quasi die relevanten, forensischen Arteffekt, Art Effekte, dass ich glaube Eiweiß ist inzwischen bei fünfzehn, oder?
Ja? Also es ist eher alt aber äh.
Der war quasi neu. Sie haben's also Sie haben den den Explode als Zero Day neu erkannt, den Sie vorher nicht kannten,
der aber von 13 in in IOS 1312 gefixt wurde. Sie haben den Apple gemeldet und eben auch die Artefakte zur Erkennung äh mitgeteilt, um jetzt Apple zu ermöglichen da irgendwie gegen.
Potentiell noch weitere Maßnahmen zu ergreifen.
Also mal wieder Spitzenarbeit vom Citizen Lab. Nicht so Spitze gearbeitet hat der Westminster Magic Sprit Squad in London,
Denn der hat jetzt den formellen Auslieferungsbeschluss für Julian Assange erlassen,
und damit liegt die Entscheidung nun bei Pretie Patel. Wir hatten in den letzten Sendungen ja schon dieses Szenario,
am bösen, dunklen Himmel gesehen und es besteht glaube ich wenig Hoffnung darauf, dass ausgerechnet sagt, ich liefere denen nicht aus, ne.
Die Chancen liegen eher bei null.
Es gibt jetzt noch eine Frist von vier Wochen, um weitere Einspruchsgründe vorzubringen. Ähm damit ist also ein weiterer Gang vor Gericht nicht ausgeschlossen. Ähm wenn Petertel nun.
Dem zustimmt, äh werden sie äh natürlich auch eine Berufung antragen äh äh beantragen. Das heißt, dieser Kampf ist,
noch nicht zu Ende, aber die tanzen auf immer dünnerem,
und immer weniger Fläche Eis um das da noch irgendwie abzuwenden und das wird glaube ich ein ein ganz ganz ganz großes äh Desaster wenn Großbritannien das macht ja? Wir dürfen an dieser Stelle nicht vergessen.
Weisen da jedes Mal darauf hin. Es geht hier um Veröffentlichungen, die ganz klar im Interesse der Öffentlichkeit und der Allgemeinheit waren, um Kriegsverbrechen.
Das geht's nicht nur darum, weil Julian Ashorster das generell gemacht hat und das zu seinen Meriten gehört, sondern in diesen spezifischen Verfahren geht es auch genau darum, ja? Also auch die,
das Verfahren oder das, was ihm in den USA dann zur Last gelegt wird, betrifft spezifisch die äh Collatoral-Mördervideos, das betrifft spezifisch die Informationen, die,
Chelsea Medding.
Der Öffentlichkeit bereitgestellt hat und da gibt es, denke ich, kaum jemanden, kaum jemanden, der das Argument führen kann ohne sich absolut lächerlich zu machen,
diese Informationen,
wichtig waren, dass die im in den investigativen Journalismus gehörten, wo sie auch gelandet sind und dass das äh eindeutig ein ein journalistischer Akt war. Und dass die Verfolgung dieser Veröffentlichung,
durch die USA mit in einer Situation, wo sie jemandem 175 Jahre Haft aufbürden wollen, das wäre das Höchststrafmaß.
So viel braucht ihr aber nicht mehr, um den Mann fertig zu machen, ne? Da reichen viel weniger. Ja das ist ein absoluter äh.
Ist eigentlich irrsinnig, dass wir in weißt du zu zu Zeiten des Friedens.
Hat man zu so was häufig gesagt, das sind ja russische Verhältnisse, ne? Und die sind's natürlich auch heute noch. Sind auch heute noch russische Verhältnisse. Ähm aber.
Gerade in heutigen Zeiten versuchen sich ja Länder irgendwie moralisch über äh vielleicht irgendwie Putin zu erheben oder Regierungen.
Das ist jetzt echt ein sehr, sehr äh also das das das torpediert diese Bemühungen.
Ich bin vor allem mal gespannt. Meine sagen wir mal ehrlich, die Chancen, dass er nicht abgeschoben wird, sind sehr gering. Ja.
Enorm gering, ja.
Und ähm mit anderen Worten man muss sich jetzt einfach mal klarmachen, das wird stattfinden und dann wird er halt irgendwie in den USA,
eingeliefert, dann ist die Frage, was passiert dann? Ist natürlich alles mögliche zu befürchten, je nachdem, unter welche politische Fuchtel er dann jetzt erst mal äh gerät.
Natürlich jetzt,
Sozusagen auch einen Klotz anbeihen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die Amerikaner jetzt wirklich unbedingt so scharf drauf sind auf diese ganze Story, aber immerhin haben sie ja diesen Auslieferungsantrag auch nicht zurückgezogen. Also mir ist nicht so ganz klar. Natürlich wollen sie dann irgendwie äh.
Da das jetzt von Demokraten äh regiert wird diese ganze Geschichte um Trump und.
Assange et cetera, WikiLeaks, äh da ist natürlich aufgreifen, also wird's also auf jeden Fall zu so einem Prozess kommen.
Das Ganze kann uns noch sehr lange beschäftigen.
Aber es ist schade, dass Europa da so äh versagt hat und ich in der Lage war mal aufzustehen und zu sagen, so hier das ist aber dann doch schon eigentlich mal eher ein Fall für Pressefreiheit.
Ja, das ist wirklich dramatisch.
Und es steht ja hier, ich will hier keine Teufel an irgendwelche Wände malen, aber ähm man kann sich ja die ähm.
Vorherigen Gründe, warum geurteilt wurde, dass äh Julian Assange nicht äh ausgeliefert werden soll, mal anschauen,
Oder mal in den Bereich der äh gesundheitlichen Probleme, auch der seelischen Gesundheit zu gehen. Ähm insofern würde steht hier auch, dass äh denke ich, ein sehr hohes Risiko im Raum, dass egal wie entschieden wird, eine.
Ein Verfahren vielleicht nicht mehr stattfindet.
Ganz ganz peinliche Sache und dummerweise echt irgendwie ein Thema, was nicht mehr also was grade wieder so untergeht, ne. Ich meine aus.
Klaren, nachvollziehbaren Gründen, aber das war so eine Meldung, ne, die ist dann so mal einen Tag durchgegangen. Ich weiß noch nicht mal, ob's da eine Push Meldung für gab, aber das wird jetzt nicht weiter diskutiert. Da kommt jetzt nicht Anne Will und lädt irgendwie jemanden zu ein, ja?
Hat sich Karl Karl Lauterbach, glaube ich, auch gar nicht so geäußert bisher. Aber.
Okay, kommen wir zu der etwas kürzeren Meldungen.
Immer mein Hinweis ein Team, das wir jetzt kürzer machen. Das heißt, jetzt wird die Sendung noch mal richtig lang. Jetzt machen wir deep dives.
Luca, Luca Sellout, der Lukas Sellout muss passieren. Wir haben damals, ich habe ihr immer gesagt,
Die wollen die Nutzerbasis haben. Die kriegen sie vom Staat bezahlt. Durch die Coronaverordnung, dann haben sie Millionen Nutzer, dann verkaufen sie, ja? Dann haben sie ja alle möglichen Geschäftsmodelle gemacht.
Sie stehen ja eben mit so vielen Millionen äh in Stolz jetzt eben da und machen die Runde bei den,
Venture Capital Buden und ich habe vor hm ich glaube inzwischen zwei Monaten schon den anonymen Hinweis bekommen,
von verschiedenen Venture-Kapitalisten, die mir sagten, Kummer,
Vögel waren heute bei mir, die wollen so und so viel Geld einsammeln, ja? Konnte dann natürlich nicht öffentlich drüber richten, berichten zu dem Zeitpunkt, aber es war ja immer klar und es war jetzt, man musste auch nicht,
Klug dafür sein, dass man sich überlegt, dass die jetzt natürlich
diese Installationsbasis zu Geld machen, deswegen haben wir auch bei der ersten Warnung des CCC vor dieser App genau spezifisch geschrieben, die machen jetzt schon Pläne für die Zeit nach der Pandemie, um die Nutzerbasis zu vergolden.
Und,
Das ist äh natürlich auch der Fall. Jetzt haben sie sich überlegt, wie weit muss man gehen, um jemanden zu finden, der nicht weiß, was das für ein Murks ist und bereit ist, da zu investieren, stellt sich raus, gar nicht so weit,
paar tausend Kilometer Richtung Osten, da ist ein schönes Land mit dem Namen Russland und da findest du ein Investor
an denen du jetzt für 30 Millionen Anteile an der Luka App äh äh abtreten kannst.
Gleichzeitig haben sie das Problem, dass sie ja eine ursprüngliche Datenschutzerklärung den Leuten angedreht haben,
in der nicht drin stand äh unser Geld wird für einen Payment Service eines äh russischen Investors äh genutzt,
sondern äh eben die quasi in den Verträgen hatten sich aufgehalten, dass sie die Nutzung jederzeit ändern können, aber wenn du deine ähm Datenschutzerklärung änderst, brauchst du natürlich die Einwilligung der Nutzerinnen.
Versuchen Sie sich jetzt schon mal langsam zu holen. Sie wollen ja jetzt so eine Payment-App draus machen und wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, machen Sie das jetzt irgendwie so ein bisschen eifer,
Alphabeter-Test, ne, also so nach und nach erstmal bei einzelnen Nutzerinnen einholen und gucken, wie die reagieren, mit anderen Worten,
wie muss deine wie muss dein Interface aussehen? Machst eine Push-Nachricht oder nicht, wie groß müssen wie klein muss der Knopf sein äh,
zum Nein sagen, wie groß muss der zum Ja sagen sein. Also die arbeiten jetzt gerade daran, äh diese ärgerliche rechtliche Hürde,
zu überspringen.
Gleichzeitig, wenn man einen Account löschen will, stürzt die App ab und wenn wir uns über die Webseite macht, kriegt man einen vier null vier.
Also es läuft alles nach Plan, ja? Kohle äh Kohle läuft. So. Gibt's einen schönen äh Artikel auch in der Zeit,
wo dann einfach mal die Frage gestellt wurde, ne, die Luca-App sollte die Bekämpfung der,
Pandemie erleichtern. Nun wollen ihre Gründer darüber,
neue Dienste anbieten und viel Geld verliehen. Dürfen Sie das?
Das ob sie's dürfen oder nicht
in dem Moment, wo die Leute einwilligen dürfen sie das, aber was sie hier mit dem deutschen Staat gemacht haben und mit der deutschen Gesellschaft ähm
in einer Notsituation äh sich zu bereichern und dann diese Nutzerbasis weiter zu verkaufen. Ähm das ist äh das äh muss nicht juristisch bewertet werden, sondern einfach moralisch.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch die Frage, mit dem dürfen Sie das.
Ebenfalls moralisch zu bewerten sind ja Crypto Coins. Tim. Hast du noch.
Ist ein reines technisches Argument. Freiheit, Freiheit.
Freiheit von äh von wem nochmal?
Freiheit, von Regeln, Gesetzen, ähm mit Medikationssteuern, genau äh Betrugsverhinderungen, all das ist nervt doch einfach nur.
Das will man nicht haben.
Netzwerk Org meldet, dass die EU an einem Bitcoin-Verbot tüftelt. Das heißt nicht, dass da jetzt fertige Pläne in den Schubladen liegen oder dass das bald käme, weil die haben,
ein paar Dokumente, die im Prinzip den Diskussion stand, also welche Parlamentarier, welche Leute positionieren sich da, mit welchen Argumenten wie und ähm letztendlich gibt es zwei,
die da jetzt als Möglichkeit der Einschränkungen diskutiert sind,
könnte die EU das Mining,
von Kryptowährungen mit Proof of Work verbieten sagt so Bitcoin Mining ist not a loud in the Neverlands.
Dann hast du aber das Problem, dass,
das ist natürlich immer noch woanders stattfindet und du dann damit einfach hier in Deutschland handelst, ne? Das heißt damit hättest du jetzt ähm
der dem Ökosystem weltweit keinen Schaden zugefügt. Das aber ist natürlich das erklärte Ziel, weil es eine fürchterliche Energieverschwendung ist in Zeiten, wo wir
uns diese Energieverschwendung möglichst verkneifen sollten, wenn wir den Planeten nicht in einen Feuerball verwandeln möchten.
Also ne, wie auch hier äh diskutiert wird, es hätte nahezu keine direkte Wirkung auf die globale Mining-Industrie und somit auf den Energieverbrauch wie,
Michelle Rauchs ähm sagt, der der Universität Cambridge zu diesem Energieverbrauch forscht. Die haben auch von denen sind auch diese Studien wie viel.
Terrawat Energie, die da für diesen Quatsch verballern. Deswegen müsste ein Verbot nicht nur das Mining, sondern eben auch den Handel mit Bitcoin treffen.
Das soll also sagt, okay äh man darf sie nicht mehr äh man darf nicht mehr offiziell damit handeln.
Handel bedeutet tauschen in äh Bargeld und damit werden die Exchanges dicht.
Natürlich jetzt diese ganzen wie heißen sie? Und,
Coinbase und was nicht alles, die jetzt, ne, die sich ja,
damit dieser Spekulation, also mit dem Handel.
Goldene Nase verdienen. Übrigens in US-Dollar. Finde ich auch immer erstaunlich. Oder eben nicht erstaunlich, dass die ihr Geld schön brav in Dollar machen. Statt in in Bitcoin, wenn das doch so eine super Sache ist.
Ist aber nicht nur ein Dollar, die machen auch Euro.
Machen auch Euro,
Und äh und wenn du dir was kannst du auch gerne USD bekommen. Oh Mann, das ist alles so ein so ein Abzug, ne? Und du siehst, das kommt. Ich sage ja immer, äh hast du ja auch schon hundert Mal gesagt, ne? Das wird erst noch so groß,
Das ist eine Finanzkrise verursacht, wenn wir uns dann endlich abschmiert,
Das ist das das Problem und eine Finanzkrise schadet auch mir, sonst würde ich die Spinner ja machen lassen, was sie wollen. Dann können sie ihren NASA Dorsch an einer an einer, wie heißt die Straße, Hermannstraße,
Hermannstraße Naserdosch, habe ich schon mal erzählt, ne? Das ist ein Dorsch, aber mit einem Astronautenhelm. Investieren wir doch Tim. Da investieren wir, weil.
Machen wir da machen wir am Anfang hundert, hundert Profit.
Nee, wir liegen einfach unserer eigenen Coin auf. So macht man das heutzutage.
Nee, wir machen Token. Ich will in Token, ich will keinen Coin, ich will den Token.
Oder Token. Hauptsache Einhorn.
Also okay, da da regt sich was, da wird jetzt mal so der Diskussionsstand durchblitzen lassen. In China ist es ja schon.
Ähm verboten. Ähm da war will ich jetzt nicht unbedingt Schiene als Vorbild sehen, aber irgendetwas muss man gegen dieses äh Phänomen machen, nicht nur aus der ökologischen Perspektive, sondern auch aus der ähm,
aus der Verbraucherschutzperspektive hier reihenweise die Leute verarscht werden.
Man kann ja über China denken, was man will, aber man kann ihn jetzt nicht absprechen, dass sie nicht schnell reagieren, wenn sie irgendwie irgendwas erkennen, was ihr System bedroht
dann.
Da können Sie dann doch sehr rabiat und sehr sehr schnell werden. Und das ähm ist so ein bisschen so manchmal die Stärke von so autoritären Systemen.
Ja also jetzt das den Satz werden sie dir jetzt in den Hals zählen unsere Coin Brüder unsere Countys.
Ja, aber ich meine, das ist sozusagen einfach eine eine eine Betrachtung. Ja, die schauen sich das halt an. Was passiert da? A ihr beratet hier Unmengen an Energie, während wir gerade krampfhaft versuchen genug äh Solar,
und Windkraftwerke zu bauen, damit wir irgendwie unsere Kohle abschalten können, weil es einfach auch in China mittlerweile angekommen ist, dass das jetzt nicht so eine geile Idee ist mit Planet verbrennen und so.
Äh da ist das jetzt einfach mal nicht hilfreich,
haben die Sicherheit gleich irgendwie in den nächsten Länder gestürzt und sie stürzen sich halt auch gerne in so Länder, die halt einfach auch arm sind
ja? Immer so mit diesem vorgeschobenen Argument so, na ja aber,
Unsere Nachfrage entsteht ja überhaupt erst äh dass der Bedarf für alternative Energien, ja was totale Nebelkerze ist, die gehen natürlich in diese Länder rein, weil da halt Energie subventioniert wird vom Staat.
Ja, teilweise mit so Ausnahmen. Das hatten wir ja im Iran irgendwie so Kirchen. Ja so die durften da halt äh,
kostenlos Strom beziehen und wo standen dann auf einmal die ganzen äh Server Recks, die Bitcoin berechnet haben? Genau da, ne
und äh das treibt natürlich für alle die Preise nach oben, weil letzten Endes hier die Subvention ja nicht erfolgt, damit man irgendwie Coins meinen kann, sondern die Subvention ist dafür, dass die arme Bevölkerung sich die Energie noch leisten kann. Und das wird natürlich damit auch total unterwandert.
So und wir äh ich meine mittlerweile wird das meiste wieder in den USA gemeint und dann trägt es halt dort,
dass der Energieverbrauch steigt und wir mit dem Bauen von Alternativen Energien nicht hinterherkommen.
Also ich habe würde die EU denkt darüber nach, ich aber ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube zwanzig vierundzwanzig ist da auch wieder Wahl. Also das das die haben das Problem jetzt wahrgenommen, kann sich nur noch um wenige Jahrzehnte handeln, bis sie's anerkennen. Ähm,
kleiner Gag am Ende, äh weil der beim Prototype-Fund, wir haben ja hier schon öfter über den Prototype-Fund auch gesprochen. Da gibt es ein Projekt, das ist der Hassreden-Tracker. Wir geben Betroffenen von online Hassreden ein Werkzeug, um sich zu wehren.
Aus der Projektbeschreibung der Hassreden-Tracker ist ein Set zusammensetzbarer Software-Tools, die es von Belästigung und Hassreden in sozialen Medien betroffenen Menschen
ermöglichen, Informationen über ihre Erfahrung aufzuzeichnen und zu teilen, Speerlisten für Twitter und andere Social Media Plattformen,
privat kommentiert und geteilt sowie Verbindungen zwischen ExtremistInnen
betriebenen Konten identifiziert und im Fall von Hassreden in Archiven aufgezeichnet werden,
Ja? Ist jetzt irgendwie die Machine, die Twitter API, die Gitarre API und versuch's quasi, sammelst darüber auch äh Daten.
Richtet sich spezifisch äh ja an Menschen, die äh von Hassrede,
betroffen sind und von wem geht Hassrede aus, häufig von Rechtsextremen Bewegungen? Ähm insofern ist da auch der Forschungsschwerpunkt dieses Projektes von Traffic Brown.
Und jetzt habe ich selber nicht ganz verstanden gab's in den USA irgend so ein Account der Lips auf TikTok heißt,
Also der ähm,
Ein soziales Phänomen in den USA ist, der gegen LGBTQ plus Leute hetzt und irgendwie halt äh ja.
Liberals irgendwie fertig macht.
Also liberals in USA sind nicht das, was die Liberalen bei uns sind, sondern das ist generell einfach so, dass linke, wir würden sagen potenziell sozialdemokratisches Spektrum.
Äh kritische CDU-Wähler, da verläuft glaube ich so die Grenze, ne?
Beim beim ähm CDU Wähler beim christlichen CDU-Wähler oder.
Bodenständige Grüne auch.
Ja, okay. Jetzt haben wir äh auf jeden Fall ist Taka Carlsen auf dieses Projekt aufmerksam geworden,
und äh das spielt ja irgendwo eine Rolle und jetzt hat er festgestellt, dass das eine forward intelligence Operation ist, weil wir schließlich vor der deutschen Regierung,
gefördert, ja, designt tolence.
American Citizens. Ja, also es gibt jetzt wir also jetzt es äh ein ja,
Intelligence Projekt, was irgendwie so CIA-Style,
in den USA irgendwelche äh Rechtsextremisten zum Schweigen bringen will und äh damit wirbt halt der,
Carlsen jetzt für dieses Projekt, was sich natürlich jetzt hoffentlich bald sehr viel größere Beliebtheit erfreut. Also du fragst dich echt, wie.
Also was sich daran so faszinierend finde, ist wie unglaublich.
Despirite designen müssen für ihre komische Hasssendung, in der sie erzählen müssen, dass die ganze Zeit hier die arme Rechten in den USA unterdrückt werden, sie auf der Suche sein müssen, um irgendwie für dieses Argument.
Oder für diese für diesen Standpunkt irgendein Argument zu finden, dass sie jetzt da irgend so ein noch nicht wirklich fertiges Open Source Projekt nehmen und das jetzt ihrer Millionen äh Hörerschaft vorführen.
Um um irgendwie den weiter einzureden, ne? Es ginge ihnen irgendwie an die Meinungsfreiheit. Sie könnten.
Könnten nicht mehr sagen, was sie was sie denken. Es ist wirklich faszinierend, ne.
Ja, aber du weißt doch, äh man weiß doch, wie es ist. Die Wahrheit spielt ja hier jetzt hier keine Rolle. Ich meine, die unterhalten sich ja auch heute noch irgendwie über Pizza Gate,
wo so ein Pädophilenring irgendwie im Keller einer Pizzeria äh aktiv geworden sein, die noch nicht mal einen Keller hat,
Und Fakten sind einfach an der Stelle vorkommen irrelevant. Es muss nur irgendwie so ein bisschen.
Klingen und wenn's da auch noch Webseiten gibt, die irgendwas, was auch nur ansatzweise diesen Bericht äh Echo verleiht, äh gibt, ja, wo man drauf rumklicken kann, sagen kann, ja siehst du hier, da ist es doch alles, die Verschwörung ist real.
Dann dann spielt es keine Rolle, dann wird das einfach rausgehauen und dann muss es nur noch böse klingen. Es geht nicht dadrum, dass es stimmt
Es geht darum, dass es ein Talking Point ist, den sie einfach erstmal in den Raum werfen
wo sich dann alle wieder dran abarbeiten müssen, ja wieso, das stimmt aber gar nicht und so weiter und hurra, wir haben die ganze Zeit wieder um über die falschen Sachen geredet und so funktioniert das halt auch bei, der halt einfach ein Tool ist,
Keine Ahnung von wem der alles bezahlt wird, aber das sind bestimmt nicht die nicht die nettesten Menschen auf diesem Planeten,
So und das fließt halt einfach rein. Ich meine, wer das nicht weiß, was das jetzt so daher gesagt, wir kennen den Vogel natürlich schon länger. Das ist halt so ein Moderator bei Fox News, der da halt einfach bei Fox News,
so ziemlich das weitreichteste, krasseste, bekloppteste Magazin, Politmagazin.
Das gleich nennen, ne, Show Abzieht, die so Fox News im Angebot hat. Also bekloppter als als Tacker Carlsen geht's
nicht mehr und auch nicht gefährlicher als TKK ist. Man kann ihn schnell belächeln, man schaut sich den Typen an, wenn man so halbwegs noch alle in der Birne hat und denkt sich nur, aber was zur Hölle hast du falsches gegessen?
Aber das ist halt einfach äh berechnende,
Propaganda für bestimmte Interessen,
Das folgt schon einem Modell und da wird,
wo halt wieder was ausgegraben, was heute
das Ablenkungsmanöver ist und wenn der Prototyp mit seinem Hassreden-Tracker da reinpasst, ich meine, das ist natürlich schon bezeichnet, dass sie sagen so, ja äh
dürfen wir nicht mehr das dürfen wir nicht mehr hassen oder was? Ja, das ist ja im Prinzip so die Aussage, die dahinter steht und das ist ja schon für sich genommen total,
absurd, ja? Die wollen uns hier das Hassen verbieten. Äh ja, genau, das wollen wir auch, aber na ja.
Die Welt ist, die weidet und das sind halt solche Figuren, solche Menschen, die,
Alles die ganze Zeit immer schlimmer machen.
Tja tja zum Glück haben wir nee ich äh doch wir haben wir haben zu viele von denen.
Zum Glück gibt's uns, wolltest du sagen, Linus, ne? Wir machen ja immer alles nur besser.
Genau. So auch nächste Woche.
Genau. Wenn wir wieder zu euch sprechen werden, denn jetzt ist äh erstmal Schluss äh für heut.
Und in den nächsten Sendungen äh in der nächsten Sendung reden wir dann über so schöne Sachen wie ein EU-Ausweis mit Blockchain.
Und Neues von der Chatkontrolle. Also das wird wird auch wieder äh schmerzhaft und,
Bis dahin macht ihr nochmal einen kleinen längeren Spaziergang, um euch zu erholen.
Genau, bis dann. Tschüss.
Bis dann, tschau tschau.